hey guys welcome to this Tuesday's
mastering the middlegame class and
grandmaster Eric Hanson current resident
GM here today I decided to pick a pretty
fun game the first game I ever looked at
that wasn't played by myself as a kid
was by the German chess master Adolph
Anderson and today I decided to pick one
of his games he was kind of the
unofficial world number one in the
1800's for period and the game I'm gonna
show is in the first international chess
tournament before he was considered the
world number one he was playing Howard
Staunton who was considered also
unofficially the world it was that kind
of like number one against number two at
the time chess wasn't super developed
but it was a big match for the time
being and back then everything was
tactical open positions and whatnot so
this should be a pretty fun fun game
Anderson is is white and Stanton is
black and this was in London 1851
you for you six g4 and g6 so I mean it's
not not the best opening but that's not
why why I'm showing the game so black is
making some weight dark square
weaknesses Bishop d3 Bishop g7
see three I'm sorry I actually first
fish to eat three probably I play
see-through first but I mean there was
no opening theory at the time so the
games are very original so that's that
this was just typical all the time we
won't judge them too hard
this was chess in its infancy but one
thing is point out as Anderson really
liked to attack so he's putting his
bishops there but you had some sort of
idea black played c5 that was the idea
C 3 C takes d4 C takes D foreign Queen
b6 and well pretty self-explanatory move
it's attacking at d4 and b2 at the same
time I don't think it was a very good
practical choice because Anderson was
known as a very tactical player enjoyed
sacrificing he was an expert in the
King's gambit so this is right down his
alley
and you know I still see this all the
time though people go and pawn hunting
but after Queen b6
I think Anderson was very happy to just
reply 92 there's no way to defend both
b2 and d4 yes Queen takes b2 and Knight
B to C 3 so why it's got all four pieces
developed for the cost of a pawn and I
mean I don't know how many of you guys
would put gold B I agree I've seen
people be really greedy you know there's
always somebody we know who likes to eat
bonds I would never do something like
this but Stanton decided to go for it
so after so now rook e1 and IP 5 was
just just natural Queen b6 really asking
for
d five or something and I mean it's one
of those positions where you almost have
too many options it feels like for sure
you have a lot of compensation and
that's that's correct and lots of
different moves here so pretty much
we're just gonna I'm just gonna go with
what was actually played but rookie one
here is decent yeah Brooke v1 could be
okay
white went for rook c1 castling would
also be okay but you know the the game
has already been set blacks taking upon
and white has to approve compensation
for that and to take advantage of blacks
position before black gets developed so
Brooke c1 first may be eyeing the C file
Knight can't go to c6 very easily here
that runs into potential like d5 so like
that so but but now the game you know
after rook c1 Blankfein 86 and that's
already still I don't actually
understand what's going on I'll be I'll
be honest I don't know what's Staunton
saw but 96 is two after Knight b5 you
know black has 97 covered that's the
reason for it but there might have been
some alternatives like 97 and just
trying to Castle I mean it's one of
those situations if I was black I might
try to give back the pawn or just try to
castle no matter what yeah the bishop
once it's hanging so so 97 was wising
maybe 97 because it protects the bishop
on c and black King been Castle but yeah
Nate at 96 same thing the bishop on C
gets protected in it and it depends c7
but that's not the really strange move
under sim plays Knight b5
and now that's when things get a little
bit weird but this game doesn't end
right away black plays Bishop to f8 this
is you know a little too much a little
too much and I think we've all the thing
the reason why I found this game also
kind of fun is I think we've all had
those games we had a really really good
opening or like all the space in the
world all the tactics that's often when
we get a little bit sloppy so many
options so so let's see what happens
with Bishop f8 keeping on d6 the best
move for sure is 97 Bishop Bishop F fate
is over protecting d6 if 97 which is
what is better blacks surviving I mean
something like d5 you can actually keep
checking I think I think you can just
keep checking Queen a5 check Bishop d2
and maybe play the Queen back to b6 I'm
not I'm not entirely sure if you know
you want to play d6 as white here or
something usually you want to open up
the position so on March 4 d5 I think I
think something here like Bishop f4 was
probably White's idea and why it's just
gonna play for compensation like castles
maybe Bishop d6 here just playing on the
dark squares but you know black just
needs to get the King out that's it's
kind of how modern chess is now I don't
think we would do that so after 95
Bishop FA that's it's a bit you know too
much and it really should be punished
really really should be punished so a
couple options would be castling here
Black's still a couple moves away from
calcium so white can castle or play play
d5 usually you want a castle anyways so
that if you ever attacked the Queen they
don't have a check in hand so castles
and now d6 still black is nowhere close
to castling so I mean I mean the
position was probably already losing
already and Anderson is probably already
just thinking his opponent is playing
very very badly after d6 I mean now
well d6 was kind of
pretty much force they're just there's
there's no way to get your King out now
you need a couple moves in d5 or it's
coming or a five
there's nothing too attractive but I
guess d6 was one reason you wanted to
play Bishop FA now d6 is really well
protected
so now White has a lot of a lot of
options here
d5 maybe f4 Queen d2 but there's like
there's no rush there's no rush to to
stop block from castling and after d5
and Anderson played d5 all those pieces
are developed to play d5 kind of direct
which makes sense you you do want to
open up the position when you're way
ahead and development black played Queen
a f5 I'm going over the opening part
kind of quickly because neither neither
side at played played too well white is
so far playing all the easy moves but
for example here white spent some time
and couldn't find like a win like I
could I would already be looking for a
win and you didn't see a direct win so
he went for something else there is no
immediate win here and that was probably
frustrating 97 doesn't work there's no
way to somehow kick the Queen off of a5
so there are some better moves than what
was played Bishop d4 was played one
example of a of an annoying move might
be just something like Queen b3 maybe
something like Queen b3 and honestly
just why not just get that you know get
your pawn back and then you don't have
to worry about anything
maybe Queen b3 and there's no real way
of defending 87 that would be an example
but I think that black was playing kind
of maybe so badly or offering so many
options for white just couldn't figure
out what to do so anderson goes for
something not as precise but still
something that understudies push up d4
anybody has a move that if I
you know why not this we can look at
that but this should be for I'm mantras
hoping as opponent will play f6 g5 is
played which is in line with the
principles if you're behind in
development you want to close out the
position to gain some time to develop
your pieces you don't want position be
open when you're trying to get your
pieces out it might be target so so
that's asking black to play e5 which is
what happened I mean of f6 take Bishop
takes Knight f4 I imagine blocks not
going to survive too much with this much
activity going on in the centre 97 is
going rook e1 Knight f6 as a threat so
ii 5 was played
Bishop's III and that's definitely
something white anticipated Queen da and
now what's and now okay you know what I
don't I don't think there's any sort of
win anymore I mean White's made a couple
in precise moves it's there's not
there's no the position a little bit
closed so white has to do some work
again there's no option to just break
open the position on u6 so the natural
move here F for at forwards plate still
trying to take that you know use that
lead in development and it and you know
Anderson was like the best attacking
player in the world at the time so you
know you had some ideas here I'm not
judging him too harshly though because I
think black you know often you play a
bit worse when your opponent's not
playing as well either you know it's
sometimes that happens and I think that
might have been being the case here I
mean you didn't have to work for it this
is just almost too easy and you get
pretty sloppy sometimes when that
happened so f4 happened now have six
not really any other move you don't want
to take on that 4f takes e5 that's
consistent you know not a move like f5
here at five I don't think blocks going
to take probably just g5y doesn't have
to take right away and that that could
have been played there's honestly in
every single position there's a bunch of
good moves like or at least why it's not
in danger of losing the advantage white
still has it that's very very good
compensation for the material so that's
not that's not a problem I have to take
c5 Stanton replied oh I have 2x + e5
back trying to keep things solid
this move is potentially playable
there's good and bad by keeping the F
the pawn on f6 black could maybe be
optimistic that you can castle keeping
that like with the final f6 maybe a
white can't start like play Bishop g7 97
trying to Castle maybe you didn't go for
it maybe I'm thinking potentially like a
move like d6 was probably what what
white should be playing automatically it
even without calculation I don't think
black can can do well at all in this
position with the with all the pieces on
the back ring so that's probably what's
scared black just to move like d6 let's
say Bishop d6 Knight these next Queen d6
Bishop e5 King e7 a position like this
sure block block is up to pawns but that
rook is going to da and there shouldn't
be there shouldn't be anything it's not
an immediate loss but black won't be
able to get any pieces off the board
when let's say that what goes to d8
yeah everything everything is stuck you
know can you 7 even like a move like
Bishop before would work check that
dicks before stuff like this it's just
it's just you know so black didn't go
for this
and it makes sense that there's tactics
working for white
you just can't violate the opening
principles like that so that's their f2
xe5 now now white plays a move that I
kind of agree with Quinte for trying to
gain a tempo get the Queen off of the
back rank I don't see some sort of you
know immediate immediate crash so Queen
f4 is at least finally you know is is
developing and that with temple there
are some other ideas maybe you could
play like Knight f4 that's that's the
possibility when Queen a4 so 97 when
they take these six is a threat next
move with a double check Queen a4 it
should be seven that's the only move if
Queen d7 what does white play here 96
check yeah yeah night-night yeah yeah
there's a 96 check this would be 5
Queen is pinned on g7 so Bishop d7 and
now again not the best move from white
white played Bishop b4 and I thought
that Bishop is the darks for Bishop it's
a nice-looking Bishop shouldn't really
go there well you play Bishop before
trying to put some pressure on d6 it's
not necessarily threatening something
which is why I have more of an issue
with that move because for example after
move like Knight f6 I think black might
be surviving on tactics Bishop d6 you
know there's Queen b6 check so I think
there's some tactics here I mean maybe
the doctors aren't working because you
know King h1 you should take these six
rook here it's it's a little messy and I
just feel like it's unnecessarily messy
even if it even if it may work that
Bishop that Bishop just seems a little
bit loose there but it slowly keeps
keeps I mean black black isn't okay by
any means but I mean a variation a
variation that the Andersen minister and
usually he's known for finding
combinations and he's a really good at
talking for a nice type of example of a
combination this position would be Queen
a3 the Queen put the bishop on d7 d6
this week and can anyone see why Queen
a3 works well nice variation there there
are there are a few but them the most
forcing would be just clean b6 check
leaving the piece and planning the take
Queen takes and rook takes FA King takes
F fit Queen d6 check and blacks was not
going to survive there are no no no good
moves here if the King goes the a Queen
e5 and of 97 the precise move
is Queen f6 probably and the king has to
go to yet if you know king air this is a
maid so white gets all the material back
with with with that with time Queen
takes a jade and everything falls so
that I mean that's not the hardest
tactic but I feel like why was playing
off a field right now you still wasn't
looking for necessarily the knockout
when just getting all the pieces in
right squares the bishop before I prefer
to keep that dark sort Bishop because of
variations like that I mean I think here
after Knight c5 there's also some
tactics you guys can see so Queen takes
e5 is a suggestion Queen c5 d takes e5
Bishop takes e5 ok does it get back all
the material or more so
so something like rook c8 Bishop H it so
this looks like it's it's close to all
the material because that's a that's a
rook and a piece for the Queen and still
an attack although it's still a I mean
you know let's say a six you move your
knight back it's not game over yet
Bishop h6 next we're like it's not it's
lucky I'm over yet even though it still
looks good for white so it's a nice
Queen sac you can play the Queen sac and
you won't lose but maybe maybe something
something else here just testing out
your tactics I'm just looking at it like
you guys what about Bishop takes e5 this
[ __ ] takes e5 pawn takes d5 what about
rook takes e5 there I don't know I
that's that's just off the top of my
head i I don't know what actually opens
up to net c5 my idea there is to play
rook takes a fait next move and do some
sort of like discover check
with the idea of rook takes of it so
after Queen b6 I wanted to play Knight
check
I probably you have to play King King u7
because I've looked xf8 check next move
maybe maybe okay then we have Knight
takes a so I think I think this is
probably why you should be five you have
to take back the bishop if you take
Knight takes Knight takes D three
there's ninety seven check yeah I think
I think here I think you're at rook
takes Fe but so Brooke takes F it's a
theme even with other dogs for Bishop it
looks it looks pretty good so that's a
tactic that was missed but you know not
the end of the world black still isn't
close to castling
so Bishop Bishop d7 Bishop b4 and now
after Bishop before black you know black
plays Knight h6 white blocks not really
going to take on before because then
Knight c7 check is coming the next move
so night h6 at this moment finally
finally Staunton started realize that he
has to develop because you didn't do
that the rest like really wrong so it
seems like now black had a little bit of
awareness I need to get my knight to f7
I need to like get my King safe and then
finally like I think you know hit him
that you know this this isn't so good so
net 86
and now this is the last move that
Anderson missed another good move this
is this is last part afterwards I think
he wakes up as well but after night at
6:00
what's a very simple and strong
continuation for for white is just
surprising because Anderson is a very
sacrificial he likes to sacrifice so can
you give me a few more muscle Rucka
Rucka fade
let's say Brooke the exact fade first
yeah yeah that's that's already pretty
nasty if rook takes FA tonight XD a
check King moves you know night check
Queen takes 86 or take a queen neck yeah
it's it's over and if King takes f8 I
just wish it takes pawn and no matter
where the King moves I don't know where
to put it
just Bishop takes you know this [ __ ]
takes pawn and that's two pawns well two
pawns and a very important dog for
Bishop but like blacks was not going to
survive there's the bishops gonna go
back here in case Queen b6 checks so
this would just be effectively lost and
it's not that hard to see once you see
the position but just from an attacking
player this is this is you don't even
need to be winning this is already it
already looks really really like really
fun to play so I would have played it
even if it wasn't winning under normal
circumstances but it seemed like the he
wasn't awake yet and then after after
Bishop e4 Knight d6
place King edge one so kind of : you
know they both decided to take a bit of
time out Black's like let me develop
when White's like yeah let me get my
king safety you know they trade they
trade moves with each other and now
Knight f7 finally now ok black black is
getting close to to developing and I
mean five moves ago black had all his
piece on the back rank so Anderson was
probably pretty frustrated here but just
continuing the attack now almost
everything is defended and now rook
takes f7 doesn't work a lot of the rock
f8 tactics don't work it's a strong move
for white in this position
not sure how I'm gonna put Queenie a3
couldn't really find another
breakthrough and he's trying to provoke
some sort of night takes before
afternoon I takes before I think Y can
throw in 97 check for example so so
Knight takes before 97 check the King
King is kind of stuck in the center
black played 95 here
best would have been Bishop e7 I'm just
giving back the material because if we
counted material black is still up upon
if you can do anything in kind of castle
I would you know say do it you know just
say don't have to worry about it for
every single move black is has to
calculate tactics and tactics every
single move black has to make sure
there's no like forced loss and here for
example let's say Knight d6 check Bishop
d6 Bishop d6 96 Queen here you can trade
off the Queen's or you can even play
something like Queen e7 and okay that
forces the Queen's off as well material
is actually even so even if White has a
good position that's not it's not
anything like before I mean you would
you want to trade off some pieces of
block if you can so I feel like that was
that was the last that was a big moment
that thought back mister and any sort of
way to trade off some pieces and get the
Queen's off the Queen Queen makes a lot
of the tactics work for white instead 95
was actually a blunder can anyone tell
me why now this is actually the last
moment anderson still still didn't play
it and this one is not not hard to see
yep
Knight takes pawn is just what is the
win but you can win upon anyways in the
last variation I showed because black is
already up upon so a pawn if it's a good
puncher the idea behind this move is
kind of common the benoni as well that's
a hint I don't think there's so many
Pannonia players here though it's kind
of a bad opening for most people but in
case anybody know any player it's a idea
that sometimes comes up
you are recouping the pond but the last
variation I said black and give up the
pawn and it's still better than I mean
if you recoup the pawn and still have a
good attack and everything sure but your
recouping upon no matter no matter what
pretty much
96 is what was was played but there's a
fairly you know yeah there's a very
direct stronger move that pretty sure
Anderson was looking for for when I mean
you would this have a position it
screams for tactics didn't see it so I
didn't play it which is the right thing
to do of course and Bishop takes e5 D
takes d5 and d6 very often the Bernie
white tries to just push that deep on
down the board because the opening of
the D file isn't really in favor of
black here because blacks not developed
anyhow but yeah this is this is a not
good 97 check and Bishop c4 are both
coming you play move like 96 Queen takes
you know Queen takes c5 with Queen takes
e5 is coming or move like here you know
Bishop Bishop c4 is probably pretty good
hitting f7 and d6
didn't see the win so 96 Bishop d6
Bishop c5 Bishop c5 Queen c5 Queen e7 so
now the materials equal and blacks
managed to trade off some pieces and
yeah Queen d7 is a pretty easy move to
play and you know if you trade off
Queens here I'm not so sure how the
position is this is when anderson kicks
it into another gear it's like you know
often sometimes you have to make some
mistakes and blunders before you start
playing well in game like i think this
is kind of he often maybe he ready maybe
when he made the move you saw the win
and you know right right when you make a
move you realize what you missed that
might have happened but from here on out
pretty powerful chest is played by white
because the position is no longer
winning objectively speaking so after
Queen takes if I've just talked about
the middlegame principals who's ahead
and development stuff like that should
you try to Queens here or keep them on
keep them on so what's a good way to
keep them on yeah you can trade Queens
or you can keep them on the board so
it's it's I don't know tough decision
for some easy for others because yeah
you can get your work to c7 that's
that's true
but I think I think there's something
just a lot more unpleasant than trading
the Queens you trade the Queens rook c7
not play 96 and black is better in this
endgame with the Queen side majority
probably Queen side majority in the
block heated past one black is probably
better which is a huge shift no he
didn't read the Queen's you do not trade
the Queen's head and development just
just no no Queen c7 keeping the Queens
on the board
attacking b7 and now pretty much weight
as White has to win the game again but I
think a lot of us have had to deal with
that like just dealing with the emotions
okay I messed up the winning position
and I have to win the game again but you
know instead of getting frustrated I
think you starts playing this part
pretty well 96 block eating the past
pawn protecting d6 and it's on a dark
square which which is quite quite
convenient it's very hard to hit that
high on d6 it's one of the best block
getting squares close to the king and
hard for a white to get any access to
you know protects b7 protect a taxi for
stops any you know covers a lot of
squares so now the game doesn't look so
so hot for white
and black buck wants to play black might
even consider playing rook c8 next move
at this moment he played another
probably objectively best move I'll let
you guys CBS can can guess it why it's
what's trying to use that development
advantage that's that's now the only
thing that's now the only thing left
that protects the pass one is blockaded
on a dark square materials even there's
a bond III can't get into the game but
blacks the white still has the better
rooks and a little bit of pressure when
I play Queen a5 I mean I want to say the
one purpose one purpose of Queen c7 is
to provoke 96 because he because if you
move the Queen let's say somewhere else
can't go to p4 and say C 3 or C 2 black
is going to Castle so Queen c7 job was
to keep the Queen's on the board and
provoke 96 which covers the f5 so black
in our Castle and now Queen 85 so that's
not something you want to do is white
but that's that's the only advantage now
then I can't go back to f7 in castle
whites Queen on a5 would be a better
place than on c5 and white could go like
rook c7 for example if black were to
move the knight back now after Queen a 5
blocks not castling rook see it's not
possible here because a sevens hanging
so you have an option between moves like
a six maybe to protect a 7 although then
rook c7 comes now though we have really
really really bad move played by black
h5 I don't like h5 at all because I just
don't think you sense the danger really
I just wouldn't want to lose my game
because I'd been messing around with on
the side for a long period so when
you're ahead and develop when you're
behind the villain you want rates apiece
so what's the better move for black here
one that makes a lot of sense just
consistent with what what which move
yeah I just work outfit look Fe you know
look at me why not manually Castle okay
if a trade off a pair Brooks if white
was to take King goes to g7 I don't know
like his black is getting more the more
pieces I get rid of its what's the
benefit black so Brooke if it was not
played at that time h5 so not really
sent getting you know well h5 maybe to
play h4 but black clearly isn't too
worried about White's attack maybe
because white men so many winning
variations earlier that at this point
black thought you could really play
almost any move but that at this moment
white starts playing pretty accurate so
what's the follow-up what's a logical
follow-up they play h5 what's a logical
follow-up for a fool
rook c7
now black realizes oh I'm getting
attacked and plays we're cafe but now
there's a big difference in the position
do you trade rook says white yeah a note
a Brooks now and now the option is you
don't have to trade rooks and black
still is playing with a rook on a King
stuck in the center board when you're
attacking just keep the pieces rook rook
after c1 which wasn't available before
so I mean these these moves are all just
consistent with playing against the King
King position keeping the Queens on the
board keeping keeping the rooks so recap
see one another precise precise move
86 was played by black now
well black maybe wants to play rook c8
but without giving up upon how long not
sure I'm not sure that's that's correct
a six was played so yeah II seven is no
longer hanging there might be some
options to play something like king f7
I'm not sure I'm a big fan of but king
f7 might have been even you know called
for here you know using that that one
chance
but
a six and now I mean this is the
Anderson the last five moves he's been
precise and he continues to show like
this is this is the Anderson that that
was considered the world's best player
for for a few years after this game the
next move next move is uh is something
white to play you're continuing the
pressure because that net on d6 is an
amazing blockade amazing block here
you're not bishop can't get to it
Brooklyn c7 doesn't have anymore moose
black played a six because he's like I
can play King up seven next move
probably what attack is there here what
was that
knight Knight d4 you like 94-94 now that
that is a move that anybody would could
miss yes because you just don't even
consider that your opponent can play
Knight d4 the bishop on d3 is very
predictable black is accounted for that
the rooks are very predictable the queen
is is on a five you can go to b6 before
but it's not attacking d6 I need more
night to d4 getting that last piece of
media because you know I think I think
what black even expected is even a good
move for white here might be Knight G
one night you want to put it out three
just to get that last piece in the game
at Knight d4 94 is a very very very it's
the best move yes if you take you know a
five game over
g5 and game game over Queen e5 rook e1
wherever that I goes u6 follows the
position cracks once at night goes away
so Knight d6 and and that's definitely
move that black probably missed and now
it's a little a little late so box
though you know in the knight on d6
sorry the knight on d4 it's going going
to e6 but that's still not necessarily
game over rook see it was played
in 86
so why does white he's been playing all
the right moves and starts to find that
killer blow but now finally getting the
piece in the red squares and and this
time doesn't really let black get away
Knight d6 rook c7 to do 97 check here
Queen c7 or Rick c7 what happens if 97
check yeah Knight take C 7 check King
King to f7 like an Bart can be better in
these end games very very easy if you go
to a pure endgame black is better with a
blockaded blocking the position or black
is fine I'll say black is fine like it
king of 7 the King goes the g7 Queen c7
there should be 6 and you have to trade
Queen's rook takes so it's really you
know f1 is covered by the bishop well
yes rook takes e7 keeping keeping pieces
on the board now King f7 now is not so
good
King a7 now because whites improve that
night there's a after king f7 you know
you can play 95 so now the king of stuck
there after we're after 94
so rook f7 is played to fit any other
work is hanging kind of a safe move
well blacks not threatening anything
Bishop e6 is impossible so Queen b6 is
by just getting that Queen to to make
sure blacks queen of stock on e7 getting
the getting the piece a little bit
closer there are no threats from from
black right now so that's the Queen b6 I
mean black is just shuffling around
really just paralyzed
that's play Brooke f6 but again like
that NATO and d6 you see like even
though White has a great position I you
know it still still there's no tactic to
finish finish black off Queen Queen b6
now what I wanted to look at here was
actually what happens after Queen b6
after Queen b6 Brooke f6 was played but
what'd you guys do I have to remove like
Queen f6 so trying to maybe just Queen
f6 the idea is you can't take on d6
because Queen f1 is checkmate and
another idea is by moving the Queen f6
you're threatening Bishop takes e6 now
the queen is not e7 and this is another
type of move that's not really based on
calculation it is a bit but it's also
just following this general principle of
like the development advantage after
Queen f6 because I want to you know I
wanna do Bishop takes e6 but I trade all
the pieces off pawn on e4 is not gonna
be too happy against a net on d6 the
last five moves White's been very
precise and I'm confident Anderson would
have found the most precise move here
that's the only move to maintain what
what points been up to but it's very
critical now Queen up ones not being
threatened because you can take the
Queen and your queen can go back to G 1
and Y will be up in exchange rook takes
Bishop d7 then I'll play Queen F 1
I'll trade a lot of pieces off although
after rook takes rook stakes d7 what
happens at 467 I think I can just take
back anyways I booked d7 we take these
seven I mean what was missing all these
simple wins earlier in the game but now
no now he wakes up a bit and shows show
some class this didn't happen but it's
an only move first of all I'm surprised
nobody has suggested h3 calm move a
little surprising no there aren't too
many checks their tenth there can't
really be killer low blows if there
aren't any checks well all the recent
moves for black for white have not been
immediately removes they've been good
moves but they haven't been forcing
moves now there aren't many checks 497
rook c8 very few very very few h3 is
very tempting as a decent move but again
it's not even the best after Bishop
takes c6 Queen takes d6 rook takes e7
Queen takes e7 you know white can be
afraid of a move like Bishop takes h3
and Queen f3 checked it should still be
good for white but there is perpetual
chances and Queen f3 no the really the
really precise move of Queen f6 was
played is to play rook c1
yeah you have to play that's what you
have to play it you have to put you have
to keep the pieces on the board you have
to not allow a bunch of pieces be traded
now Bishop e6 queen dick sorry Queen
takes d6 and Queen be a check is coming
next move so White's winning material
while still keeping the Queen's on the
board with blacks King position still
bad this okay White's gonna win upon
probably and the king is looking me
stuck so it's not you know it's not a
killer blow but it's just consistent
with the last few moves white yeah you
got it avoid the the exchanges here
that's really that can flip the
evaluation so each three I could have
accepted as a move although it's give
some tangible rook c1 and you get
another crack at it you get another
crack at getting into blacks position
unfortunately rook f6 is played
well that's a bit easier so h3 still
making sure the back rank is clear
hey black still can't move easily right
King up 795 here and now HC there's no
more checkmate threats a black is really
paralyzed so just is gonna make some
moves g5 then a very nice very precise
move by white here but this time there's
no man threat so it's you know you guys
should get this one try try to cash in
this position block is paralyzed I'm not
saying there's a checkmate or anything
here just you know turn this into some
sort of material or something something
much cleaner so we're gonna have six
does have some tactics against the Queen
on b6 if you move that night b2
well now if night night f7 defending it
well b7 hangs whatever so no way to
defend e5 just know it if the vendee 5
the pieces are not ideally a plays good
luck
so nothing special but we've seen a
transition anderson started off the game
guns blazing sacrificed the pawn got all
the pieces in didn't play the right
moves and now has had to win the game
over again almost positionally with as
you know with not as many pieces as
before which makes it a bit harder so
Queen B - and now now positions just
collapses the game finished very quickly
here after night b5 it should be 5 pawn
takes b5 Queen here
say h4 rook d7 check last few moves were
just a formality
look be a check King g7 d6 look at it
game was a couple moves longer but you
know it's game over
but you know white had to switch gears
and that's that's a hard thing to do in
chess to admit you know you missed her
attack mister win and win the game over
again but a very very nice nice nice
finished by white and hopefully that'll
help you guys a bit when you have a big
development manager you have an attack
there are a lot of decisions here that
were quite thematic in terms of keeping
the material on the board and in making
you know playing against King position
how many moves the move was 44 moves to
checkmate and I just showed to no 40 so
I went four more moves those checkmate
and they used to play tell checkmate
pretty much so those former moves but
that was I thought that was a bit of a
rollercoaster of a game not the highest
quality but then in the end white
composes himself and plays some really
really good chest